[Música]
Rusia denuncia un ataque masivo con
drones en la región de velgorot que ya
fue escenario de incursiones el lunes
reivindicadas por milicias opuestas al
kremlin nuestra enviada especial habló
con estos grupos y le explicaron que
Ucrania conocía sus planes y los motivó
a ejecutar la ofensiva
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
rinde cuentas en un escenario distinto a
la sede del parlamento un acontecimiento
marcado por el decreto de muerte Cruzada
con el que el mandatario disolvió la
asamblea y adelantó las elecciones
conectamos con quito
el líder de la cámara de representantes
Kevin mccarthy anunció que una
delegación republicana volverá esta
tarde a la casa blanca para avanzar en
las negociaciones sobre el techo de la
deuda el país está a una semana de
entrar en situación de impago
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos con información relacionada con
la guerra en Ucrania porque este
miércoles Rusia denunció un ataque
masivo con drones en la región de
belgorot fronteriza con Ucrania una
ofensiva que Moscú atribuye a kiev y
recordemos que la misma zona fue
escenario de una incursión el pasado
lunes reivindicada por milicias
ultraderechistas formadas por ciudadanos
rusos Opuestos a Vladimir Putin y que
vinculados con la legión extranjera
luchan a favor de Ucrania en esta guerra
precisamente estas milicias conocidas
como legión libertad de Rusia y cuerpo
de voluntario rusos citaron a la prensa
en la provincia ucraniana de sumi en el
norte del país nuestra enviada especial
Catalina Gómez Ángel estuvo allí y habló
con miembros de estos grupos que le
aseguraron que kiev estaba al corriente
de sus planes de atacar
este encuentro con estos dos grupos que
realizaron esta incursión en territorio
ruso desde el pasado lunes se llevó a
cabo en una región no muy lejos de la
frontera en la provincia de sumi en
Ucrania se nos ha pedido no revelar la
locación donde nos encontrábamos lo que
si vivimos y lo que pudimos conversar
con ellos es un grupo de considerable de
hombres muchos de ellos acababan de
regresar de territorio ruso hablamos con
los representantes de cada uno de estos
grupos la legión de Rusia libre y el
grupo de voluntarios rusos se les
preguntaba Cuál era la diferencia entre
ellos y es más o menos ideológica el
grupo de voluntarios es más de derecha
de extrema derecha y ellos dicen que no
tienen nada de malo en serlo que ellos
no van con esvásticas ni levantando la
mano para saludarse pero que si tienen
una filosofía de derecha Pero qué más
adelante posiblemente los puedan Llamar
nacionalistas ellos explican varias
cosas que no contaron con la ayuda de
Ucrania pero sí Ucrania sabía y los
motivó a hacer esta incursión ellos
niegan haber tenido
blindajes dados por occidente a pesar de
esas fotos que han aparecido en los
medios Ellos dicen que se trajeron
varios trofeos de guerra uno de ellos
los tenían en esta presentación pero
dicen que si bien aparecían allí jambies
y otros blindados de origen occidental
eran tal vez tomados por Rusia en su
momento en batallas dentro de Ucrania
aunque no lo dicen muy claro Ellos dicen
que la Gran Victoria es haber podido
demostrar que pueden cruzar de un lado a
otro de la frontera y que los rusos Allí
se dieron cuenta de que estos no eran
grupos de papel que estaban en el
internet sino que eran grupos reales y
que esto solamente el principio de
incursiones y demás trabajos que harán
posteriormente
y por otro lado el líder del grupo
Wagner y Eugenia declaró que 20.000 de
sus mercenarios han muerto en la batalla
de batmut la más larga de esta guerra y
de los 20.000 muertos Diez mil eran con
Víctor reclutados en cárceles rusas
necesitamos prepararnos para una guerra
dura que debemos hacer en esta guerra
para no enojar a Rusia porque ahora
Estamos en condiciones de enojar a Rusia
ese es el problema principal necesitamos
imponer la ley Marcial Lamentablemente
debemos declarar nuevas oleadas de
movilización durante la ley Marcial
debemos transferir todas las
instalaciones posibles para producir
municiones
vamos ahora a Israel donde el parlamento
aprobó el presupuesto del Estado para
los próximos dos años lo que incluye un
aumento de la financiación para escuelas
y seminarios de la comunidad Ultra
doxa veamos a los detalles de la nueva
ley de finanzas en el siguiente informe
de Juan Pablo lucumí
una sesión maratónica que inició el
martes y terminó en la mañana de este
miércoles con 64 votos a favor y 56 en
contra el gobierno israelí logró la
aprobación del presupuesto Estatal para
2023 y 2024 el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu celebró estamos sorprendiendo
en la economía estamos aprobando un
presupuesto responsable un presupuesto
que se mantiene dentro del marco un
presupuesto que recibe elogios también
de las agencias calificadoras tengo un
último mensaje para nuestros amigos de
la oposición no creen falsas
expectativas este gobierno cumplirá los
cuatro años de su mandato
mientras al interior del parlamento se
discutía la extensa lista de objeciones
de la oposición liderada por Yahir la
Pitt a las afueras distintos sectores
sociales protestaron en contra de la
medida
este presupuesto es en realidad una
culminación y el siguiente paso a la
Reforma corrupta en el sistema judicial
está enteramente dedicado a propósitos
que No servirán De nada para promover el
crecimiento y desarrollo de Israel en el
futuro
y es que de los 270 mil millones de
dólares del presupuesto al menos 4 mil
millones serán destinados en fondos para
partidos Ultra ortodoxos y procolonos
como los aumentos para que los hombres
ortodoxos estudien a tiempo completo en
seminarios religiosos en lugar de
trabajar o servir en el ejército así
como un aumento del 50% en las
inversiones a escuelas Ultra ortodoxas
que son ampliamente criticadas por no
enseñar a los estudiantes habilidades
como matemáticas e inglés necesarias
para el sector laboral moderno
vamos ahora a Ecuador porque en medio de
la crisis política desatada por el
mecanismo de muerte Cruzada el
presidente Guillermo lasso rinde cuentas
de su último año en la presidencia en un
auditorio de quito la capital del país
Allí se encuentra precisamente nuestro
enviado especial Rodrigo sedano Rodrigo
Buenas tardes para usted este lugar
donde usted se encuentra y donde tiene
lugar este acto no es el emplazamiento
habitual de este tipo de acontecimientos
no
Pues así es Rosa Buenos días también
para ti estamos como bien decías en un
auditorio del barrio quitum en el sur
del país del sur de la capital quito un
barrio Popular de aquí de la ciudad y no
es el lugar habitual este este discurso
habría tenido que haberse dado en la
asamblea pero precisamente se encuentra
cerrada tras esa declaración de muerte
Cruzada del presidente Guillermo lasso
un Guillermo lasso que ha empezado el
discurso recordando la batalla de hace
200 años de pichincha que dio lugar al
inicio de la independencia del Ecuador
la Comparado y además ha hecho una grave
una dura crítica a la oposición a quien
ha dicho de que han intentado llevar los
afanes golpistas al país ha dicho
también que esa muerte Cruzada la
decretó precisamente para que el pueblo
ecuatoriano ecuatoriano pueda decidir
Cuál es el futuro del país en las urnas
ha dicho que esta es una decisión por la
vida del pueblo ecuatoriano precisamente
de este mecanismo de muerte Cruzada que
como usted decía protagoniza este
acontecimiento se desprende una
convocatoria anticipada de elecciones y
este mismo miércoles hoy se espera que
el Consejo Nacional electoral de la
fecha exacta que se sabe
Pues mira Rosa te puedo decir que justo
antes del comienzo de este discurso de
Guillermo lasso hemos podido hablar con
la presidenta del cne que nos ha
confirmado a la cámara y al micrófono de
France 24 que el 20 de agosto será la
fecha para esa elecciones también esta
noche habrá una locución a la nación
donde se terminará de confirmar esa
fecha como repito 20 de agosto fecha de
las elecciones y de unas consultas
populares también sobre explotaciones
petrolíferas y minerales en unos parques
nacionales del país ahora espera una
carrera presidencial con mucho ajetreo y
en la que los partidos tendrán realmente
poco tiempo para presentar a esos
candidatos y para preparar Esta carrera
presidencial en la que como decía el 20
de agosto van a votar de nuevo los
Ecuatorianos Rodrigo pues muchas gracias
por este reporte iremos conectando a lo
largo de la jornada
nosotros cambiamos de información vamos
a Estados Unidos que está en vilo a una
semana de que según el departamento del
tesoro el país entra en situación de
impago Y es que tras varias reuniones
republicanos y demócratas no logran un
acuerdo para aumentar el límite del
techo de la deuda esto debido a las
grandes discrepancias sobre cómo
gestionar el gasto público sin embargo
el presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarce declaró que las conversaciones
con la Casa Blanca continúan
enviaré a nuestro equipo de negociación
a la casa blanca hoy para tratar de
terminar las negociaciones con la Casa
Blanca hay varios lugares en los que
todavía estamos muy separados quiero
decir no pareciera que fuera a ser así
de difícil
Bueno antes que nada Permítame decirle
al público estadounidense que no me voy
a rendir no vamos a incumplir vamos a
resolver este problema me quedaré con él
Hasta que podamos hacerlo pero seamos
honestos sobre esto tenemos que gastar
menos de lo que gastamos el año pasado
no es mi culpa que los demócratas no
puedan renunciar a sus gastos
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque hoy
hace un año del tiroteo en una escuela
de ubal de Texas en que un hombre armado
mató a 19 niños y a dos adultos y a esta
hora avanza la investigación sobre la
tardía respuesta policial que permitió
que el ataque durara 77 minutos sin
embargo la restricciones al porte de
armas que piden los familiares de las
víctimas continúan bloqueadas y esto que
los incidentes con armas de fuego son la
principal causa de muerte de niños y
adolescentes en el país Ramiro cué
Barberena nos cuenta más
la tragedia de la escuela primaria Duval
de cumple un año el 24 de mayo de 2022
un tirador de 18 años irrumpió en la
primaria rock y protagonizó un ataque
que duró 77 minutos
19 niños y dos maestros murieron las
heridas siguen frescas para la comunidad
de esta localidad de Texas como es el
caso de Verónica mata madre de tés una
de las niñas asesinadas
tenemos que aprender a revivir nuestras
vidas
porque nuestras vidas no son las mismas
y nuestras vidas nunca serán las mismas
Entonces siempre falta esa pieza
Sabes quiero decir
realmente no hay nada que pueda detener
lo que estoy sintiendo A menos que
puedan traerla de vuelta pero no pueden
hacer eso
en paralelo continúan las
investigaciones sobre el crimen y la
deficiencia respuesta de la policía que
demoraron intervenir y luego dio
versiones contradictorias para
justificar su accionar
esta semana es una semana difícil ni
siquiera podemos imaginar el dolor que
las familias están sintiendo un año y
nos damos cuenta de que todavía no
tienen las respuestas que necesitan y
eso nos ha frustrado a todos pido
disculpas el gobierno de Estados Unidos
incita en la necesidad de leyes que
restrinjan la posesión de armas mientras
eso parece un objetivo lejano las armas
de fuego son la principal causa de
muerte de niños y adolescentes solo en
2022 se registraron más de 300
incidentes en instituciones educativas
causando al menos 270 muertes mientras
en 2023 ya hubo por lo menos 33 hechos
de esta clase
y cerramos en Francia donde continúa la
edición 76 del festival de cine de Khan
y nuestra enviada especial María
Carolina piña no se reporta las
actualidades el último delirio
cinematográfico de wes Anderson y el más
reciente drama del italiano marco
velozio entraron en la competencia de
cannes
[Música]
el excéntrico West Anderson regresó a la
alfombra roja de cannes con la última
locura de su autoría asteroide City es
una fábula de extraterrestres y niños
científicos en un desierto de colores
chillones
largometraje de wes Anderson lleva su
sello inconfundible una estética precisa
movimientos laterales de cámara humor
ácido y una buena dosis de situaciones
absurdas las películas de West Anderson
están plagadas de estrellas de alto
calibre y así es asteroide City Tom
hanks Scarlett Johansson
eran tantos que llegaron en un autobús
al estreno de la película en el Palacio
de los festivales
[Música]
el italiano marco trajo a la competencia
de Canes un drama histórico sobre el
secuestro de un niño judío por el
Vaticano en el siglo 19 repito El
secuestro narra la verdadera historia de
Edgardo un niño judío de 6 años
arrancado a su familia por la iglesia
luego de que una de las sirvientas de la
casa lo bautizara en secreto cuando era
un bebé intenta ganar la palma de oro
con este drama sobre la crueldad del
Vaticano un caso que tomó dimensiones
políticas y que llevó a la comunidad
judía internacional a desafiar a la
iglesia hasta que las noticias
[Música]